je voulais dit tout à l'heure dans
propos introductif il faut dès à présent
préparer là près de juin je crois qu'il
faut faut que ça marche comme ça je n'en
attendais pas de moi que je vous dis ce
qui va se passer après le 2 juin
j'ai un cerveau envie de dire à ce stade
de nos échanges ce dont on est sûr c'est
que ça dépend un peu de nous tous c'est
à dire ça va beaucoup dépendre de la
réussite des trois prochaines semaines
qui nous mène à cette échéance qu'il
faut que chacun j'allais dire prennent
et assume ses responsabilités d'état
bien sûr d'abord l'ensemble des
collectivités puis nos concitoyens on le
sait bien ce la réussite de la sortie du
confinement sera d'autant plus
importante que chacun pourra respecter
les règles élémentaires de lutte contre
ce virus en tout cas de prévention
contre ce virus vous les connaissez les
gestes barrière le respect de la
distance physique et social le port du
masque dans tous les endroits où nous
avons souhaité et demandé qu'il soit
porté bref